hier envoyé effectivement que les russes
étaient en train d'avancer il avait
réussi le pari qui était en fait de
contourner ces verrou donetsk à part le
sud est de pouvoir du coup attaqué la
ville plus par le bas et des
journalistes allemands sur place disait
hier que la ville de l'isie jones était
tombé et que donc dans ces conditions on
voit effectivement que les russes
avancent alors ça veut dire qu'ils sont
sur cette petite poche en fait est que
cette poche avec ces deux villes leur
permet en fait de continuer à pouvoir
prendre le territoire dans le donbass et
qu' ils veulent effectivement prendre
tout cette aube la sq pour l'instant de
louhansk qui est en haut et qu'ils
s'occuperont ensuite de descendre un peu
plus mais là ils sont sur les positions
qui sont autour de ces dayraut donesk
alors la question derrière c'est que le
gouverneur ordonne aux siens de repartir
et comment vont-ils le faire on ne sait
pas exactement combien ce qu'ils sont
effectivement les forces chrétiennes qui
sont en train de se battre en ce moment
on parle de 500 on parle de 2000 voyez
même la quantification est difficile
mais à partir du moment donné où ils
reculent ça veut dire qu'ils sont pris
en étau avec les russes aujourd'hui qui
fondent de tirs d'artillerie qui
justement ont tiré non stop et qui n'ont
absolument pas envie de leur faire de
cadeaux les rivières sont coupé les
ponts sont coupés dans ça va être
compliqué à aujourd'hui pour les soldats
ukrainien de quitter envie sert de hesc
les russes qui restent fidèles à leur
stratégie qui est la conquête totale du
dombass désormais face à des ukrainiens
qui espère reprendre du terrain mais
comment alors il espère reprendre du
terrain parce que leur vision c'est de
pouvoir à un moment donné récupérer
quand même une ukraine qui ne soit pas
si divisé que ça et que du coup ils
voudraient revenir en arrière sur la
question du dombass ça on le sait ça
fait partie des déclarations par exemple
du président céline ski mais ça c'est
des déclarations qui vont diplomatie et
qui vont pour faire du bien au moral
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui immédiatement
tout de suite l'armée ukrainienne elle
essuie un tirs intensifs des russes
depuis maintenant quelques semaines dans
cette remontée il y a évidemment des
morts il y a des blessés il y a des
blessés importants c'est-à-dire des
blessés qui ne vont plus être apte au
combat et que donc ça va être difficile
d'avoir un moment donné une armée aussi
importante et aussi motivé premièrement
alors l'enjeu c'est est ce qu'il va y
avoir les armes occidentales est ce que
les armes occidentales vont pouvoir les
aider oui les américains ont envoyé des
lance-roquettes par exemple avec la
dernière génération ils ont mis du iman
pour pouvoir être plus compétitifs sur
le territoire certes mais encore faut-il
que les ukrainiens les et à temps et que
effectivement ils sont encore assez
nombreux dernier point la politique
jusqu'à présent du président céline ce
qui s'était ne perdait pas de territoire
battez-vous ce qu'ont fait les
ukrainiens avec beaucoup de courage
beaucoup de courage parce que sous le
tir de l'artillerie russe ça doit être
effectivement extrêmement violent quand
vous avez autant de tirs 24 heures sur
mais ça veut dire que dans ces cas là il
ya des pertes et qu'à un moment donné
quand on repart en arrière est ce
qu'après on voudra revenir en avant
c'est pas évidente dans l'art de la
guerre